ce dernier battu de la russie jeudi
foued artères grosse dark dark and to
maître gims énorme barca
j'adore parfois ça me rend un peu
rassurant mais grosse mare carrée de
presse l'hiver d'arc à ce que les gens
il s'habille bien en hiver je trouve
mais meira sera pas ce que c'est je
préfère l'été à l'etat sera parce que ce
que je quitte le foot est donc skiff
l'om mais je suis plus psg chante en
anglais d'arkham et plus grosse d'arqués
encore pour le français dark assez cool
c'est cool race rassure certains trucs
mais globalement d'arc à dark app store
ils veulent vraiment bien ra sera parce
que ce qu'il ya quand même des gens qui
massacrent la langue française sur
twitter
gros zarka pour fanny ardant énorme
marca parce que parce que c'est avec
quelques du coup j'ai tourné dans le
premier film et elle était avec moi
total marca
cros détente et mais je les adores et
humainement et puis artistiquement de
l'observer c'était ne sont quotidiennes
à chaque fois donc énorme barca
sur toi
[Musique]